demon souls remake let's go i have
so much edited content prepared for you
in the coming weeks
but man the game is still fresh in my
mind so i kind of need to gush about it
now
case in point actually while i was
editing this i noticed that that
dregling catches fire
from his buddy's torch that's a small
taste of what's to come
because the attention to detail the game
is just dripping with it
knowing me the series will probably only
be a few episodes but i'm going to try
and do at least one episode
per world and it'll be edited so that if
you see
my camera on screen it's a stream
highlight and if not
then it's post commentary first up
character creation which
is so detailed now but be careful with
your choices
okay you got to be able to like make
ugly character yeah you can make ugly
characters
so in this game you can stack
regeneration or in the original you
could
so the plan is get like five different
types of regeneration and just stand
there and not die
that's the goal let's go
king by channeling the power of souls
brought unprecedented prosperity to his
northern kingdom of boletaria
that is until the colorless deep fog
swept across the land
moletaria was cut off from the outside
world
and those who dared penetrate the deep
fog
never returned
of the royal twin fangs broke free from
the fog
and told the world of politaria's plight
[Music]
but the old king of land had roused the
old one
the great beast below the nexus from its
eternal
slumber and that a colorless folk had
swept in
unleashing terrible demons
the demons hunt down men and claim their
souls
those who lose their souls lose also
their minds the mad attack the same
and
also spoke of the enticing power of the
demon spoons
each time a demon claims a human soul
the demon's own soul is invigorated by
the life force
and the power of a mature demon soul is
beyond
human imagination
the legend spread quickly mighty
warriors lured by the possibilities
braved
the fissure to breach the accursed land
but none have returned
pure of the twin fangs
yet the silent chief
sainter bane
scurver the wanderer
the sick saint destroyer with her night
girl vignette and sage freak
the visionary the colorless deep fog
slowly creeps beyond
boletaria's borders
[Music]
humankind faces a slow and steady
extinction the deep fog
will eventually swallow all lands near
and far but
volataria has one final hope
a lone warrior who has braved the
painful fog
oh has the land found its savior
or have the demons found a new slave
he walks weird
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so what's happening here is you're
entering the fissure that was left by
valafax
who came to this land before you and was
the only one to escape
and he basically forged the way for
everybody else to come after him
okay good good run
interesting
nice
so they changed the weapon animations
but one thing they said that they did
they made them all different animations
but they kept the cadence of the attacks
so they're all like the same speeds um
and similar hitboxes i guess
all right spin to win let's go
oh that's so cool get a backstab
okay all right there you go here's your
animation chat
[Music]
damn
that's so [ __ ] cool all right
backstab backstab
don't mind me just getting behind you
oh [ __ ] your spine dude oh and then the
king hit
all right i have to do a fist weapon run
at some point these animations are just
too good
also watch this clip when you two hand
your weapon you actually get
another unique backstab animation it's
funny the first hour of our stream was
just
me looking for new weapons to test out
the critical hits with it's impossible
to resist
yeah you saw what happened to the other
guy didn't you
so we punch our way to the demon
vanguard and
beat him first try ask anyone ignore
that this is a different
character anyway his is one of the more
controversial remake designs
simply because he looks a lot more
grotesque here than he does in the
original
in the original he's a bit more goofy
looking and a lot more alien
if that makes sense so the debate
surrounding all these design changes is
a really big one and i don't have my
full thoughts on it
so to put it simply i've played for
about 10 hours now and
i can confidently say at this point
anyway the remake
is so faithful to the original game i
think it's actually
faithful to a fault in some cases but
the handful of jarring changes that i've
experienced right now
they don't really bother me and i think
they were actually inevitable in a
project of this scale
but the important thing for me is what
makes up for these
missteps and what you think is a misstep
is going to be different for you but
what makes it up for me at least so far
are some of the braver design
changes that they've managed to pull off
the back stabs the reposts the punches
the mind-blowing attention to
environmental details
and perhaps most impressively for me
the new facial animations i'm stockpiled
thomas
look how it zooms in when the scotch
came
i didn't know what happened look at the
mouths when i came to
i found myself here this is good
animation right
it's not bad my wife and daughter
fell victim to the demons
but i would be worthless in battle
at the very least i hope to lend my
assistance to you
brave slayers of demons there's just so
much
character in these facial animations and
i feel like it does justice to the voice
actors that
they've managed to track down again for
the remastered narrations
just think about previous souls games
this even puts sakura's lip syncing to
shame
and i feel like honestly this is one of
those leaps forward
that would set a new standard in from
software's games
except it wasn't achieved by from
software it was achieved by bluepoint
so i like it so far maybe you feel
differently but
i feel like if eldon ring doesn't have
this it's a step backwards
so what i'm cycling through now are all
the filters in the game
and when you start you should make sure
you do some serious experimenting with
these filters
and also the options as well you'll want
to change things like the camera mode
and motion blur and there's a ton of
other stuff that you usually don't have
to do in a console game
uh my favorite filter is the classic
filter what's yours what i'm less
impressed by
are the exclusives within the digital
deluxe edition
if you drop that extra 20 you pick them
up from stockpile thomas
and you know in the end they were
exclusive you can't drop them for other
players
and my first impressions of the weapons
anyway is that they're quite powerful
although i still have to test that but i
will be avoiding the weapons for the
most part for my first playthrough
but i am testing out one of them in
boletaria so let's go there
and man these load times are fast the
ssd in the playstation 5
is actually amazing
uh
i can't even see
oh my god it's not over yet there's a
fire weapon
and it burnt all of the sin the timbers
that's cool
okay so two hits to kill
yeah my control is vibrating when he
throws the fire
in like a really like fluttery kind of
way as if it's on fire if that makes
sense
so this is like another example of
situational awareness like i was not
even
i feel it i feel the fire on my
controller when he does that
so it's a good way to like know what's
happening off screen i guess
cool with a little flourish
okay so that's the rapie
photo mode on the touchpad
okay off we go
okay you can't go too far photo mode
it's insanely powerful
and it's going to be an absolute meme
machine i saw some people complaining
that it's a way to
unfairly pause the game but i think
that's kind of silly for one it's locked
behind
three button presses so it's not exactly
convenient in combat
and secondly secure had a one button
pause
and i think that was actually healthy
for the game so in any other from
software game
photo mode would be like who cares but
this is blue point we're talking about
and you are constantly in awe
of the visual detail on display and
photo mode
allows you to truly stop and admire
what's going on in every scene
you have to remember also this video is
rendered in 1080p
and on top of that the stream recording
isn't perfect so the quality at 4k on my
end probably looks about four times
better remember that
so photo mode is valuable and it's very
valuable for creators who need this kind
of mode for thumbnails as well
so on that note i want to announce a
competition submit your best photos to
demons challenge
gmail.com making sure that you put the
words photo mode competition in the
subject line of your email
along with your paypal and i'll give you
fifty dollars if i use your thumbnail in
a video and i'll give a hundred dollars
to the person who takes the best photo
overall you can only submit one
and it's due at the end of november i
should also mention that i'm running
nine other demon souls gameplay
challenges for over four thousand
dollars in prizes
so if you have a playstation 5 before
december 17th when all the competitions
end
consider watching that announcement
video in the description and contribute
with the inbuilt playstation 5
gameplay capture or even just start
practicing with the original game
because
so much of this game is still the same
you can still abuse the hell out of
backstabs that's for sure
they haven't changed that
they didn't bother miyazaki's vision was
100 correct the first time this is kind
of what i meant
earlier when i said that the remake is
honest to a fault
demon souls had pretty abusable
backstabs and
it's something that i would have been
interested in seeing them tweak
i could go both ways on this though in
some ways it's actually really charming
that a lot of the classic
jank is still in the game and i can't
repost this enemy while he's standing on
the stairs for example
that's some good next-gen nostalgia and
man i love this clip where the other
hollow just leaps past me blowing up the
barrels
and smolders in the background as i take
out this guy
okay so when you go through this fog
gate you can jump over this
and you can talk to ostrava
that was a bold leap a surprise indeed
well now that you are here pray thee
fend off these draglings
so here's a list of the videos that i
plan on making in the coming weeks
subscribe if any of this looks
interesting to you for example i'll be
covering every npc
quest line in one video so i won't go
crazy in depth on ostrava here
but for now the theme of this video at
least is i cannot get enough of these
animations
the only problem with them sometimes is
their length
oh no i shouldn't have started this
animation i'm gonna get killed by an
animation
wait did his head his head's looking at
the dragon
look at this i think i think i think
he's moving his head towards sound maybe
that's how it works look he's looking at
the dragon that's so cool
does the tail hit you
look at them like looking around for me
[Applause]
yeah it was a bad idea why do i do this
don't do animations with the dragon to
end this video
i'll fight the boss and the thing i
actually want your opinion on here is
the music
so i'm gonna raise the volume on that
and let you compare it to the original
as well
while you're watching please check out
the links in the description if you want
to catch this playthrough live follow my
twitch if you want to watch the full
stream vod
subscribe to vati vodya my second
channel and
if you love souls games as much as i do
consider repping your pride with one of
my displayed posters
the painted world and convergence for
example are both full of easter eggs
that only
souls fans will understand and there's
another demon souls inspired one coming
out soon
so let me just take a quick shortcut to
phalanx
all right there we go i know you guys
watch me these sick tips
and i'll see you next time it's an honor
to be able to share this with you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you